i need to talk about some something
first off before we even get into this
story
have you seen what demi lovato looks
like now
that's her now i knew she did one of
those
weird leftist self-haircut things which
i don't know what that's about
but um she got a little
here's the story apparently she said
that she had an eating disorder and she
was bulimic and she got help and that's
why she gained weight
yeah i know when i used to use opioids a
lot too i mean eating was
now she looks like she works at the post
office
yeah seriously dude i guess uh i guess
demi you're learning like the rest of us
huh
it happens getting off opiates sucks
[Laughter]
being skinny is cool as [ __ ] check out
this story this is great but this is not
why we're talking about her
besides the fact that she's dressed like
a russian mobster
this is the definition of pathetic demi
lovato is branded stupid for ordering
l.a frozen yogurt shop the big chill to
do
better and slamming the storm's harmful
messages so here's what happened no
we're making fun of her because she
looks like a photo negative of eve
oh god i'm just gonna do a song with
[ __ ] gwen stefani
demi lovato was slammed by fans on
saturday after she criticized the big
chill which is a frozen yogurt shop
over the excess of diet geared inventory
after taking the instagram
to hit out at the shop for its
triggering options
the singer 28 was subject to mass
scrutiny on twitter
for the stupid attack and for slamming
sugar-free options
which are in fact essential for
diabetics in her original post
she penned this is what she said on
instagram about this yogurt place
finding it extremely hard to order froyo
from the big chill when you have to walk
past
tons of sugar-free cookies and other
diet foods
before you get to the counter before
adding the hashtag do better
the store situated on olympic boulevard
is owned by a
diane dennell and her daughter carrie
russell who revealed in 2011 that they
averaged a thousand customers a day
uh in the week and up to 1300 on the
weekends
demi accused the shop of harmful
messaging
from brands or companies that perpetrate
a society that not only enables but
praises
disordered eating the establishment
responded to the sorry not sorry
songstress
in a direct message which she
subsequently posted online
the company responded by saying we are
not diet vultures
we cater to all of our customers needs
for the past 36 years
we are sorry you found this offensive
lovato responded
not just that your service was terrible
so rude the whole experiencing was
triggering and awful
triggering so she was complaining
because they had like they have
sugar-free yogurt and stuff
and they was like can you believe that
you know it's it's diet vultures
when the entire internet left us in
riotous go
hey you know diabetic people can't have
sugar and sometimes they want frozen
yogurt
so now diabetic communities all after
going like you know diabetic people
and not just like type 2 ones the ones
that get it but the ones are boring the
type 1 diabetics are like
hey we enjoy frozen yogurt too that's
why they have sugar-free frozen yogurt
or how about just people who aren't fat
how about people that just
don't want sugar or cutting sugar or get
a tummy ache from sugar
yeah like i uh i've been looking at like
dietary things and cutting out things
and sugars
on that list of things it's gonna have
to go and
i'm not gonna just avoid it forever at
every circumstance but there's times
where as an adult you start going
i gotta start cutting some of that out
you got something without sugar in it i
still wanna have a nice little
cold treat right now but i can't eat
sugar but you're right it's like
everything is this but she's doing what
she's projecting all of her insecurity
and her anger
at a cupcake shop at an ice cream shop
like this is what
i have to find crusades to be angry
about things when
really isn't isn't having choices the
whole point of running a good business
oh look at that they have gluten and
sugar-free options
how cool of them i don't care i'm not
going to eat that [ __ ] but how cool that
they have
she doubled down of course she did
because she advised the business you can
carry things for other people without
also
caring for another percentage of your
customers who struggle
daily to even step foot in your store
oh my god this woman is a [ __ ] hey
um word of advice demi just start doing
it
and you at least were a little more fun
and skinnier and prettier and trashier
and you probably
again when a girl like you was on the
you're skinnier you're looking good guys
like me even have a shot
it's amazing for everybody but the
minute you get off junk you just find
yourself
[ __ ] and moaning at twitter on a
cupcake shop over there sugar-free
options and it's not you're not fun
go back to doing the junk you can find a
way to provide an environment for all
people with different needs including
eating disorders one of the deadliest
mental illnesses
only second to opioid overdose don't
make excuses just do better
so she's comparing yeah uh sugar
to opioid overdose yes well her mental
illness or mental illness of overeating
or not overeating purging uh the
what other people say artists then
advise the business on a different way
she can improve the issue she penned i
was thinking maybe it would help if you
made it more clear that the sugar-free
options and vegan options are for that
labeling snacks for celiac or diabetes
or vegans
no no go [ __ ] yourself it's a lot easier
to say sugar-free because some people
are on keto some people are on atkins
some people don't want sugar some people
are diabetic the [ __ ] the [ __ ]
nerve of this
yeah the whole point is to be clear and
say
because look like roy said some people
are cutting out sugar and not gluten
some people are cutting out gluten and
not sugar so people are cutting out this
some people so the whole point is to say
yeah the one thing you're trying to not
have this doesn't have that
thank you that's all that's all i needed
to know
uh she's what's not super clear the
messenger gets confusing and being in
l.a it's really hard to distinguish
diet culture versus health needs i think
clear messaging would be more beneficial
for everyone
you aren't wrong for catering to many
different needs
but it's not about excluding one
demographic to cater to the others
fan soon responded in anger writing
what's your favorite internet beef right
now minus demi lovato forgetting
diabetics exists
that's that's actually very funny i do
love that everybody's trolling her
though yeah
no they really are because like this is
what we need we need more of this again
like
not cancel culture and all that [ __ ]
but we do need to bring
mockery and shame back to our society
because it works
like we we used to have a system in
place where if
if a celebrity started acting like a
whack-a-doo on [ __ ] twitter
everybody could team up and goof on them
and meme them and put karen haircuts on
them in photoshop
and mock them and make them feel bad
about themselves and then they get
better
pierce morgan actually wrote an article
about this i'm triggered too by nasty
arrogant frozen
yogurt brain celebrity bullies like demi
lovato
trying to ruin small family businesses
during a pandemic
by playing the victim in such a pathetic
manner the big chels
the big chill sells delicious frozen
yogurts i know because i've been there
many times
it's delightful family run store in the
basic strip mall in
westwood los angeles that i often visit
in pre-pandemic times because it was
just five minute drives from my home
sometimes i'm having an eating day and
pile into the biggest and most calorific
frozen yogurt pie on the menu
uh and others and sometimes i want to be
healthier so i order many of the
fat-free options fortunately there's
plenty of choices the big show boasts
having over 400 flavors the secret of
success that it never changed as much
and it always looks the same and serves
up its family sweet treats and
on a daily basis it's been going on for
36
years superbly run by co-owner diane
denau
and her daughter carrie russell and has
become an iconic
presence in l.a serving a thousand
customers a day when the new york times
profiled the big chill in 2011 and
explained its enduring appeal despite a
lot of competition by saying
typically when we think of good examples
of branding we think of companies like
apple
which never changing products and
relentlessly inventing marketing blah
blah blah so saying the place is
consistent
um lovato
let's keep going the official definition
of an increasingly popular word is to
have an
intense emotional or physical reactions
such as a panic attack
after encountering a trigger not a day
goes by without some celebrity
somewhere claiming to feel triggered by
something mainly an attempt to
weaponize victimhood and raise their
profile and make money
if this sounds unduly cynical of me then
permit me to borrow words for miss
lovato's own smash [ __ ] sorry not sorry
last week we had to endure the sickening
spectacle of the talks
cheryl underwood claiming to have
suffered ptsd
following her bust up with sharon
osbourne oh my god that's right
so pierce morgan has been defending
sharon osborne and sharon osbourne
defended him right
so that that woman that cheryl underwood
claimed ptsd
well clearly the only ptsd that i have
witnesses miss underwood is post
trashing sharing derangement syndrome
which manifests itself in playing
victimhood after killing your co-workers
career
but by the flimsy yardstick requirement
to claim such victimhood i am most
definitely feeling triggered today
not by poor demon lovato having to
witness the existence of
fat-free fruits and yogurt witness the
existence of
it's very funny a fat-free pose of
yogurt which is obviously a deliberate
attempt
by the big chill to give her an
immediate eating disorder he's being a
real
[ __ ] no i was triggered by miss
lovato herself
uh the more this repulsively arrogant
woman
attacks this lovely little store in an
unhinged delusional manner the more
furious i became
how dare she try to destroy the big
chill simply for doing its job
one that does very well uh to the
widespread popular
acclaim who the hell does lemmy lovato
think she is
well we know who she is now don't we
she's revealed herself to be a horrible
piece of work
who thinks the middle of a pandemic that
has crushed so many small businesses
is the perfect time to crush yet another
business using the full power of her
huge social media presence
i've been some i've seen some revolting
celebrity behavior during covet crisis
but little to rival this
let's be very clear demi lovato wants to
wipe out the big chill because it
provides healthy
frozen yogurt for all types of customer
many of whom have medical conditions and
need it
she finds that thoughtful inclusive
behavior model triggering and demands to
do better
to which my response is i find idiot
celebrities like demi lovato triggering
and require them to do better
hilariously uh and with yet more
astonishing lack of self-awareness
lovato later posted the following quote
from the late great
poet and civil rights activist no
maya angelou no she wrote on our it's on
our instagram
this is about frozen yogurt she wrote at
quoting maya angelou
each time a woman stands up for herself
without
knowing it possibly without claiming it
she stands up for all women but then you
claim it
so then it doesn't it kind of right guys
demi lovato is the modern maya angelou
she's a civil rights fighter frankly
she's a civil rights hero
holy [ __ ] dude oh i'm sorry but who's on
your mount rushmore of civil rights
i've got demi lovato demi lovato
dmx oh
doctor
your nickname is tinas
yeah she seems pretty uh unhinged do you
need to go back on
at least you know at least then you were
too zonked out on
to really [ __ ] about [ __ ] yogurt and
you were
you know she's quoting my handshake yeah
dude because she's this is frozen yogurt
fighting for justice [ __ ] what are
you doing